لقد حدث ذلك في حفل توم جونز في
ويلز، وهو حدث عائلي، ولكن عندما
لاحظت بنات أخت كلير ديفيز أن رجلاً غريبًا كان
يداعب عمتهم من الخلف جيدًا
بالطبع قاموا بتسجيله، وقد
رددت تعبيرات عمتهم تلك العبارة الشهيرة
لتوم جونز،
وكانت عمتي شخصية كهذه، لذلك عندما
حدث هذا، كان الأمر مضحكًا جدًا،
كل شيء في لغة جسده كان
يصرخ "إنها ملكي" وما جعل الأمر أكثر
تسلية هو
الأغنية التي كان يغنيها توم جونز
على الرغم من الوجوه التي كانت تجعلها تجعلك
لا تلتفت أبدًا وتقول "مرحبًا يا صديقي، سيدة
خاطئة، زوجة خاطئة، لا لم أفعل"  كنا
جميعًا نضحك، لذلك لم يكن الأمر
مهينًا لذلك، لقد ذهبنا للتو
مع التدفق وذهبنا مع التدفق
حتى اللحظة التي أدرك فيها أنني
أداعب شخصًا غريبًا
وأشار إلى زوجته الحقيقية جوان التي
كانت لديها نفس الشيء  لون الشعر وسترة الدنيم توأمان
عمليا،
كتب المداعب جون جونز على
صفحته على الفيسبوك تبين أن لدي
زوجة خاطئة يا سيدي توم، أنت ذو تأثير سيء
قال مازحا أوه، لقد كدت أن أقبلك
أيضا، كان ذلك سيكون أسوأ مما
نشرته زوجة جون.  كنت منشغلة جدًا بتوم
ولم ألاحظ حتى أن زوجي يحتضن
امرأة أخرى باستخدام المصطلح الويلزي الذي
يشير إلى الحضن، واعتذر جون للعمة كلير،
لكن المعلقين عبر الإنترنت تأثروا
بلمسته، حيث بدت وكأنها لمسة محبة للغاية،
أعتقد ذلك، نعم، أعتقد أنه بدا "
أ"  رجل حقيقي جميل حقًا، نعم
الشيء الوحيد الذي انفجرت فيه هذه القنبلة الجنسية
هو الضحك
العبقري لقناة سي إن إن
نيويورك